Our next guest
is a very talented actress
who stars as Princess Diana
in the brand-new season
of "The Crown," which is
streaming right now on Netflix,
and everyone is watching.
Here is Emma Corrin.
Emma, thank you so much
for doing this.
I'm so excited
that you're here.
-Hi. Thanks for having me.
I'm excited.
-I was going to ask you
how the last few months
have been in quarantine,
but then I saw this photo,
and I think it pretty much
sums it all up.
You playing cards with your dog.
What stage of quarantine
was this?
-This was actually
very early quarantine.
-Okay.
-This was, like, peak lockdown.
Hadn't been outside the house
in a very long time.
And we found ourselves here,
yeah,
playing spit
with my little puppy.
-There's a rumor I wanted
to ask you about because --
And tell me if this is not true.
Again, I get all my info
from Wikipedia.
And I run the website, so
actually I make up the rumors.
So you should thank me later.
But I was --
Apparently I heard this,
that you have
a very famous dog walker.
I read -- I don't know if you
know what I'm talking about.
I read that Harry Styles
walks your dog.
-Ohh.
-Is that true?
-Yeah. He -- Sort of.
He once dog-sat for me.
-[ Laughs ] He did?
-The thing I love about this
is also my dog has no idea,
which is I think
the wonderful thing about it.
For a dog, it's just a person.
But, um...
sort of near where he lives.
And he looked after Spencer
for me.
But not again.
He hasn't done it again.
And I think it's because
halfway through the meal
I got a message that just said,
"He won't stop farting.
Is this normal?"
And --
-Was it from Spencer
or from Harry?
-[ Laughs ] From Spencer.
"Emma, I'm not
doing this again."
-[ Laughs ]
How good of a dude
is Harry Styles.
What a nice guy.
Pal, "The Crown"
premiered this weekend.
Everybody I know --
I had to text everyone and go,
"Stop. Don't tell me. Don't --"
They're like,
"Yeah, but this happened."
I go, "Don't tell me anything."
For anyone who hasn't
watched it yet,
could you set up what's going on
this season of "The Crown"?
-Yeah, I play Diana from when
she's about 16 years old
to when she's about 28,
so a long, long time.
And, yeah, I love this season
because it follows essentially
three incredibly
brilliant women --
Well, sort of debatable.
But, well,
very interesting women.
The Queen, Diana, and Thatcher.
And sort of looks
at their relationship
to power and these powerful
positions they've been put in
and how they grapple with it.
So, yeah, we see these
sort of stories unfold
throughout the years
and how they handle it, yeah.
-Well, not only did you get
the look down, the hair,
but the voice was perfection.
And then I read somewhere that
you also do a good Charles.
-I think so.
I spent a lot of long time
on set trying to copy Josh.
-So, how would you give me
advice on how to do Charles
or how to do Diana?
Could you?
-Yeah, yeah.
Do you want a lesson?
Oh, my God. Yeah, sure. Okay.
So, Charles, the thing
they say is to basically --
If you want to say "yes" --
If you want to get into his
voice, you say the word "ears."
Like ears. Ears.
-Oh. Ears.
-Ears. Ears.
-And that's how
you're saying "yes," basically.
-Wow! That is hilarious
that he says "ears."
-That kind of helps. Ears.
-Ears. Ears.
-And what I always did
for Di was, "All right."
And she always kind of
goes down at the end
of everything she says.
So it'd be like, "All right.
Are you all right?
I'm all right."
-[ Laughs ]
See? You're very good.
"I'm all right.
Are you all right?"
-I'll say to you -- I'll say,
"I'm gonna go in the other room
and watch the news."
And you say, "All right."
Okay?
-Okay.
You're going to be Charles?
-Yeah. For this first scene,
I'll be Charles.
-Okay.
-Ears. I'll be in the next room
watching the news.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Great.
-That's pretty good.
Now let's switch it around.
Ready?
-Okay. So I'm Charles? Okay.
Ears. I'm going to go into the
other room and watch the news.
-[ Laughs ]
-You sounded French!
You sounded like
Inspector Clouseau.
-[ Laughs ]
-[French accent]
Do you understand?
You cannot understand
what I'm doing.
I'm going to the next room
to watch the news!
-[ Laughs ]
-All right.
-All right!
-Yeah, I can't --
I don't know who I'm doing.
I'm doing, like,
a bad Cyndi Lauper.
-I don't know what I'm doing.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Emma Corrin
in season four of "The Crown."
Take a look at this.
-I suppose the greatest
highlight has been, well,
well, meeting all of you,
the people of Australia.
You've made us feel
so welcome, so at home.
-Well, perhaps. Because
you've been so refreshing.
You're not what we expect
from royalty.
-Well, that's because I don't
think of myself as royalty.
First and foremost,
I'm a wife and a mother.
That's what's
most important to me.
-She really is
a wonderful mother.
-And how's William
getting along?
-Oh, he's having
a magical time here.
-So he likes Australia?
-Let's put it like this.
His favorite cuddly toy
used to be a whale,
but since coming here,
it's been firmly supplanted
by a koala.
-Emma Corrin.
Season four of "The Crown"
is streaming
right now on Netflix.
Please come back on
whenever you want to
and congrats on everything.